[Musique]
premier numéro du 7 8 dossiers pour
cette année 2010 9 et nous allons parler
et solidarité ils oeuvrent tout au long
de l'année auprès de celles et ceux dans
le besoin les bénévoles des associations
sont encore plus sollicités en cette
période hivernale nous avons voulu mieux
les connaître et aussi vous présenter
leurs actions au quotidien
nous partirons tout d'abord pur plaisir
au sein d'une antenne des restos du
coeur puis à montigny le bretonneux
auprès de la boutique alimentaire et
puis elle nous terminerons par une
maraude ses interventions de nuit auprès
la des sans domicile fixe solidarité ils
oeuvrent au quotidien c'est le thème du
7-8 dossier pour ce mois ci
[Musique]
il s'appelle dominique xavier ou encore
mireille et ont tous un point commun
plusieurs heures par semaine ils sont au
total une cinquantaine de bénévoles ici
au sein des restos du coeur de plaisir
on a de bons peuples
voilà à la distribution des produits
frais didier il est encore en activité
mais sur son temps libre il vient en
aide et une semaine sur deux je m'étais
dit il ya quinze ans de faire ça quand
je serai en retraite et après je me suis
dit pour la presse est un peu loin
autres profils jean-paul en retraite
il vient les mardis et jeudis matins en
donner des cours d'informatique
c'était pour avoir déjà une occupation
occuper d aider des gens qui avaient
besoin
au début je n'étais pas l'informatique
je m'occupais de d'aller dans les
supermarchés récupérer la marchandise
ensuite j'ai aidé à la distribution est
depuis trois ans et l'atelier
informatique et d la principale
motivation qui pousse tous ces bénévoles
à franchir la porte de ce centre des
restos du coeur
après une matinée d'essai ils sont
intégrés ou non à l'équipe s'il n'y a
pas de critères établis il faut
néanmoins posséder des qualités humaines
surtout est à l'écouté des autres parce
qu'effectivement ce n'est pas qu'à
problèmes alimentaires en général il ya
d'autres problèmes autres et là dans ces
cas là il faut il faut savoir être à
l'écouté et puis pouvoir rediriger après
ce qu'on a des équipes de relais quand
même mieux qui s'occupe de tout tout ce
qu'il peut y avoir d'autres problèmes
comme le logement ou
des problèmes financiers jeudi vers 9
heures ok comme la dame qui vient que je
viens de voir là mais bien presque
toutes les semaines pour différentes
les lettres de manu administration des
choses à numériser 210 familles ont
majorité plaisir oies sont inscrits dans
ce centre selon la structure de leur
foyer elles viennent une ou deux fois
par semaine pour la distribution
alimentaire
alors j'ai du jambon si ça peut vous
intéresser des nems comme ça d ouais il
ya de tout des bénévoles et il ya de
tout dans les accueillis aussi dont il
ya des gens il ya des gens qu'on connaît
depuis quinze ans qu'ils sont là qui il
ya des gens qui tirent pas alors je
dirais là
le mauvais côté de ce qu'ont les gens
parce qu'on sait pas s'ils viennent si
c'est positif au négatif
on espère que c'est positif mais des
fois on sait pas la vie et c'est ça qui
manque un peu
c'est à dire le après en fait engagement
investissements chaleur humaine
voilà ce qui ressort après cette matinée
passée avec les bénévoles des restos du
coeur de plaisir des bénévoles qui
agissent ensemble pour faire vivre la
solidarité voulu il y à 34 ans par
coluche
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur je vous donne la liste
des produits vous pouvez acheter chez
nous comme chaque jeudi
janick est à l'accueil de balises qui
depuis trois ans est bénévole explique
aux bénéficiaires leurs droits et
surtout prête une oreille attentive
on en profite pour aborder avec eux
leurs problèmes et les écouter essayer
de voir ce qu'on peut
comment on peut faire pour les aider il
ya un énorme besoin d' écoutes chez les
gens qu'on accueille ils ont besoin de
parler de leurs problèmes même si nous
on va pas leur trouver des solutions
miracles c'est évident de le fait d'en
parler au japon leur fait du bien
38 bénévoles se relaient pour accueillir
les 55 familles familles monoparentales
chômage ou baisse de revenus et les
bénéficiaires peuvent venir sur une
durée de trois à quatre mois
ils sont adressés par les services
sociaux de quatre communes
saint-quentinoise
en général quand elles viennent chez
nous c'est pas la première nécessité ces
familles qui ont un projet qu'il est en
venant ici ça leur permet de je dirais
de réaliser ce projet et avec l'ambition
de s'en sortir alors sortir de l'eau
mais en les responsabilisant sur leurs
achats
et quand ils viennent chez nous ils ont
des montants d'achat qui leur sont
alloués on essaie de s'adapter à la
situation globale familiale
[Musique]
de la famille des conditions de vie des
conditions de recherche d'emploi les
enfants c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
paramètres qui peuvent entrer en ligne
de compte
sundgau les produits d'entretien
alimentaires ou d'hygiène balises qui
propose environ 300 références à prix
réduit un panier de 60 euros dans le
commerce ou vaut une trentaine d'euros
dans cette boutique on va les acheter
tellement dans certains magasins on est
livré par d'autres on a d'autres qui
viennent par revivre et éventuellement
des collectes et puis ce qui vous arrive
de temps en temps de faire des fadettes
également chaque mois une commission
étudie les dossiers des demandeurs
l'association existe depuis maintenant
24 ans financé par les communes saint
quentin en yvelines le département et
des dons son budget est de 210 mille
euros
[Musique]
vendredi soir il est 20 heures et les
bénévoles de la croix rouge de saint
quentin en yvelines chargé le camion
pour effectuer une maraude jusqu'à
minuit on peut répondre par rapport à
une aide vestimentaire alimentaire accès
aux soins à travers comment tout ce qui
est soins soins dentaires dentifrice
brosse à dents par exemple et autres
besoins demandé par la personne
rencontrée
l'action sociale de la croix rouge
française de saint quentin en yvelines
englobe 31 bénévoles ce soir cinq sont
présents donc et l'oea n'a pas pris
l'udc dominique la roselyne ils viennent
en renfort du samusocial 78 de novembre
à mars
parmi eux il y as n'a fait des maraudes
depuis quatre ans elle est devenue chef
d'equipe il y a deux ans et demi ça
m'apporte la satisfaction de la
satisfaction dans la mesure où honnête
de les gens et quand on voit le travail
des personnes qui sont volontaires et
que et qui sans qu'ils arrivent à s'en
sortir mais malgré tout ça fait vraiment
ça fait du bien
durant ces opérations des liens se
créent entre bénéficiaires et bénévoles
nous avons nos habitués qu'ils sont dans
le secteur près de chez nous donc
notamment georges que
qui est un sdf depuis 17 ans on à la rue
donc on sait ce qui leur fait plaisir de
manger donc lui par un bojan chez le
chocolat au lait donc on ne sort jamais
sans chocolat au lait à chaque maraude
il y en a est en contact avec la
régulation pour connaître les
différentes missions de la soirée en
cette période de grand froid l'unité
locale met en oeuvre des dispositifs
spécifiques pour des personnes vivant
dans la rue vers les hébergements
d'urgence comparé l'hôpital mignot au
service des urgences ce cas de personnes
qui nous attendent à tous les coups il
va falloir les amener à satory dans le
temps au chu ce soir après avoir
récupéré les deux bénéficiaires aux
urgences de l'hôpital andré mignot du
chesnay rocancourt
les bénévoles de la croix rouge les
emmène au chu le centre d'hébergement
d'urgence de satory à versailles
on va bientôt s'occuper de vous laver
d'un rien messieux hockey bottine je te
laisse aux bavards georges et puis je
t'appelle canton l'équipe ok bon
d'érection montigné les bénévoles se
rendent disponibles et sont au plus près
des personnes rencontrées vivent dans la
rue à l'image de george à la rue depuis
17 ans les bénévoles de l'unité locale
de la croix rouge vont toujours lui
rendre visite
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait une foule à
la grenette
les bénévoles répondent aux besoins
fondamentaux des personnes rencontrées
chocolat tous des amis des compotes
règles ben ouais comme georges 124
personnes sont suivies à l'échelle de
l'agglomération
[Musique]
pour refermer ce dossier la parole à une
ancienne bénéficiaires des restos du
coeur grâce à l'association elle a
réussi à traverser l'une des épreuves
les plus difficiles de sa vie elle
témoigne à coeur ouvert le 7 8 dossier
revient à le mois prochain d'ici là
l'actualité est à suivre au quotidien
sur tv 78 une fois par semaine marie
laure miro seront au centre des restos
du coeur de rambouillet bonjour vous
allez bien
rendez vous pour lequel elle a ses
habitudes
les sacs de près comme chaque
bénéficiaire des restos du coeur elle
était accompagnée d'un bénévoles qui
l'aident à composer son panier en
fonction du nombre de points dont elle
dispose pour elle et son fils alors là
oui on donne la viande
donc on nous propose un peu surfait les
et du frais une fois le caddie plein
marie laure a pour habitude de rester
pour un café l échange avec les
bénévoles et les autres bénéficiaires
qui la connaissent bien c'est toujours
agréable
il ya deux ans marie laure subi de
lourdes opérations entraînant des arrêts
de travail prolongé auxiliaires de
puériculture elle ne peut plus porter
d'enfant elle est reconnue travailleuse
handicapée
la microcrèche pour laquelle elle
travaille l'a licencié pour inaptitude
physique est très difficile pour moi
parce que du jour au lendemain mais j'ai
perdu mon métier et puis mon envie
d'exercer c'était une passion pour moi
sa pension d'invalidité de deuxième
catégorie 2 544 euros par mois et son
allocation retour à l'emploi d'environ
180 euros par mois
l'aide mais ne suffisent pas plus que
des paniers alimentaires les restos du
coeur lui ont apporté du soutien dans
cette épreuve difficile
la joie et l'espérance
et puis nous redonne à un punch
formidable ans parce que quand on est un
peu déprimé et tout il arrive à nous
nous sortir la tête de l'eau disons pas
son âge j'ai fait le tricot mais ça fait
aussi tricoter rapide parce que marie
laure n'a jamais perdu le sourire grâce
à l'aide de son chien nacho et de son
fils vincent avec lequel elle entretient
une grande complicité
tous deux ont pu assister à un spectacle
au théâtre des champs-elysées offert par
les restos du coeur on a eu des fous
rires avec mon fils et mon ami qui du
reste du coeur aussi qui est mais qui
était venu avec nous alors voilà là la
fameuse photo abaca furaya pour marie
laure et son fils la situation s'est
améliorée
elle a retrouvé un emploi adapté à son
handicap elle est d'un enfant autiste
dans son programme scolaire 20 heures
par semaine avec ce revenu
supplémentaire plus besoin de se rendre
aux restos du coeur
elle tient à laisser sa place à d'autres
personnes dans le besoin ils font
tellement chose pour nous que je vous
dire on les remercie pas par l'argent
mais on les remercie par des petits
gestes etc
c'est un scellé ouais je suis lui parce
que c'est des gens mais formidable mais
alors maintenant
[Musique]